we are also going to ban the use of tick
tock on government devices
we will do so with immediate effect
Mr Speaker this is a precautionary move
we know that there is already limited
use of tick tock across government but
it is also good cyber hygiene
given the particular risk around
government devices which may contain
sensitive information it is both prudent
and proportionate to restrict the use of
certain apps particularly when it comes
to apps where a large amount of data can
be stored and accessed
this ban applies to government corporate
devices within ministerial and
non-ministerial departments but it will
not extend to personal devices for
government employees or ministers or the
general public that is because as I have
outlined this is a proportionate move
based on a specific risk with government
devices